it's amazing to me that you
never even googled the guy you played in
my movie to like even see what he looks
like google didn't exist right but it it
shocks me that you've never even seen a
picture of the actual guy no i've never
heard him never seen him nothing that is
so amazing because gary and i were just
saying you you are almost
word for word identical really it just
sort of happened organically and i don't
know i still to this day can never
figure out well that's why you're a
great actor that's not that's what
character how did you create it i don't
know all i knew was that i was supposed
to have this kind of stupid southern
accent that's all when i went in
betty thomas said to me just do some
stupid colonel sanders kind of action
and that's what i did so that's all i
knew and then it was really well written
but out of curiosity why not look up
what the guy looked like i didn't know
he was a real guy oh i mean i i was
familiar enough with your program that i
knew there was a guy but i didn't
realize it was that guy so i didn't
think i was supposed to look up him you
thought maybe it was a compilation i
thought it was a bunch of guys like the
the typical bad radio guy exactly no no
but there's an actual guy and he nailed
it completely are you one of those
actors that stays in character all the
time i don't recall you doing that in
front of you didn't even see
i realize now when people are in the
movies actors talk about other actors
and they'll say gee working with paul
makes it easy it does because i remember
doing scenes with you thinking gee those
were i never had a problem with any
scenes we did we didn't have a real
reaction because he was so yeah
i mean that was one of the first movies
i'd ever done so you guys were really
easy to work with what movies had you
done before you got the role in private
parts
there's one movie i got to ask you about
was it were you in a film called thunder
pants about a kid who couldn't stop
farting yeah that was after that was
after yeah that was the big stuff
private parts
thunder pants was about a fart and kid
movie i thought it was before private
now i forget after private partnership
was set no no it was a period of time a
couple of years after
so after private parts it seems like in
my memory you just became this big star
but it wasn't that way you finished
private i got a lot of good work though
right but but thunder pants comes your
way and what do you play in thunder
pants i play uh like a cia agent or
something i'm not even sure what it is
i'm playing and you're a ci agent who
has to investigate thunder pants i kind
of kidnap this kid and take him to nasa
because they want to power a rocket with
the kid's farts it's a fine it's a fart
man it's a fart man oh my god no it's
totally fart man i never heard of this
movie it's a great it's british thunder
pants underpants so the kid farts and he
has such a powerful fact that they want
to power a rocket so you come from nasa
i come from you come to recruit this kid
i kidnapped the kid does the kid oh you
kidnap him because he's napping he
doesn't want to help nasa why wouldn't
it
i don't know we have to whisk it's all
top secret i mean it's not like you were
asking him to blow up somebody you asked
him to power a rocket that could
essentially send this to the moon yeah
then the kid's game then the kid's up
for it oh he realizes yes then he's up
for it yeah i mean why go to the problem
why go through the trouble of kidnapping
top secret idea was this based on a real
story as well i don't know something
happened with that movie it never made
it to the stage but i was very eager to
do it and the reason i got it is the guy
was a big private partner was he really
big private and did they pay you a lot
of money no
so your salary what was the big movie
after private parts that got you noticed
i think it got me noticed yeah like
like what all of a sudden everyone was
trying to make more money for it yeah no
not didn't make more money but the one
that because all of a sudden you became
like a big fan it was that peak car the
harvey the rvp car thing yeah that was
the big movie i guess but you didn't get
paid a lot of money for that
anything so what was after harvey p car
that was the big moment uh
i guess sideways sideways right yeah
yeah right i didn't get paid for that
either yeah when do you get what movie
did you get i got paid for planet of the
apes did you yeah decent money pretty
decent for me would you do thunder pants
too sure yeah
you